voilà le cinéma lui s'il ya de fiction
s'est pas encore emparée de ces
évènements du 11 septembre dernier la
pudeur peut être encore mais un film
sort aujourd'hui dans les salles en
france il s'agit de onze courts métrages
confié à onze réalisateurs de renom onze
réalisateurs différents qui nous donne
qui nous livrent leurs interprétations
ces événements un résultat très
contrastées marie-jo jean-jacques ulrich
une oeuvre collective pour la réflexion
et la mémoire
onze minutes 9 secondes et une image
pour porter leur regard de cinéaste sur
une tragédie qui a bouleversé le monde
ils sont deux générations et d'horizons
différents leur univers sont politiques
ou politique
je pense qu'il ya eu 6 milliards
d'individus qui se sont raconté une
histoire en voyant cette histoire je
veux dire le il faut bien que le malheur
des autres servent à quelque chose
ok c'est ça qui m'a intéressé montré que
la fin d'un couple ça pouvait être aussi
la fin du monde ça peut je ferai aussi
faire autant de mal voilà
si le loup choisi le couple l'iranienne
samira makhmalbaf utilise les mots
d'enfants afghans et fightnews en
choisissant le point de vue des enfants
qui sont l'innocence même j'étais sûr de
ne pas prendre parti mais en même temps
d'instaurer une certaine distance avec
les événements voilà pourquoi c'est une
cinquantaine d'enfants afghans réfugiés
en iran qui s'exprime dans mon film qui
ne tient qu'à daegu aux rescapés de ce
réveil a filmé par le bosniaque danis
tanovic ou enfants africains qui veulent
capturer ben laden bien la solitude d'un
vieil homme qui a perdu sa femme à
l'ombre des tours
sean penn seul réalisateur américain du
collectif lui prend la tangente
humaniste
je n'ai surtout pas voulu apposer la
vision attendue d'un cinéaste américain
parler pour prendre la défense de
l'amérique est faux je parle d'abord
pour moi et puis tous ceux qui partagent
cette sensibilité le but du film mieux
appréhender les répercussions du 11
septembre
et puis aussi ouvrir une réflexion sur
l'avenir du monde paradoxe le film n'a
pas encore de distributeur aux états
unis